[Music]
oh my goodness you guys
do you see all of these items so this is
gonna be a video talking about the past
few months my experience with the
iphones and how much i'm loving them but
then
i checked my mail and rhino shield sent
i think
everything on their website like
absolutely they just went to the website
and shipped it to my house
so huge thank you to rhino shield for
sponsoring this video they have a bunch
of amazing black friday deals going on
right now and if you use i just need to
check out you can get an additional 10
off all of your purchases so now it's
time to show you guys some of the stuff
like i'm so excited because i love
accessories for my accessories they have
crash guards
for your apple watch they even have
cases for your air pods
they have various types of cases like
the mod nx
crash guard nx and the solid suit so
what's cool is with this mod nx
you're able to customize it with these
different types of back plates
you can actually customize these with
photos or text
your name logo anything you want you can
put this on here and if you didn't
upgrade to an iphone 12 this season
that's okay because guess what they also
have
tons of different accessories for
previous gen phones
so these are for the iphone 11 drop
tested
3.5 meters impact protection
look at that military grade find me out
on the iphone battlefield
so when you pair one of your rhino
shield protective cases with
the impact 3d screen protector you're
going to get so much extra protection
enhanced durability now it's time
to dress up my iphone what do you want
to wear today screen protector
i like this it's a little brainstorm
a brainstorm cute one
okay this is what i've picked oh this is
gonna be beautiful this is fashion
everybody
what is this what does a fox say
oh my gosh i love this oh this looks so
good on the blue so for my personal
phone
i got the silver pro max and this is one
of my review units but there is just
something
about this blue that i just i almost
wish that this is what i would have got
for myself
because it's so pretty we're gonna have
a really great
mix and match sesh right now
look at that look at that look at that
that's cool
i'm going to change out that color to be
the blue
you've got so many options it's it's
overwhelming
oh yeah look at that that's cool so if
we want to have this on without a back
plate
we can have this cool little outer rim
all right now i'm gonna match
my apple watch to it i have never put a
bumper on my apple watch before this oh
my fashion
should also put on our 3d impact shield
the rest of this video might get wild
we just can't ever be too sure
[Music]
i'm gonna pop on my bumper look at this
matching beautiful
family now where's my half watch band
that looks nice oh this looks really
good i think i'm getting into apple
watch bumpers
because like it completely changes the
look of my apple watch it's nice
it's very light too so you don't
actually it doesn't feel any different
i'm going to clean up my desk a little
before we continue with this video so
watch this
[Music]
it didn't it's still here it didn't work
let's try it again
okay ready
wow look how clean this desk is it's
like magic thank you again rhinoshield
for sponsoring this video you guys are
amazing and if you guys want to check
out anything on their website everything
is 60
off right now due to those black friday
sales and if you use i just unit
checkout you'll get 10
off as well so many cases so little time
let's carry on now we need to talk about
basically the last
few months of iphone season i feel like
this tech season has been absolutely
never ending and i couldn't be happier
because
so many incredible things have come out
not only have we had like non-stop waves
of iphones
we also got new macs we got new ipads i
have a new wrinkled shirt
that i'm just noticing now
so dating all the way back to october we
were brought
into iphone season with the iphone 12
and the iphone 12 pro this was really
exciting because
this was the first time that we really
were able to get our hands on these
devices
and really see what they're capable of
and of course this entire year has just
been so strange so at this time it was
the first time that i traveled home to
visit my family and i had to bring
everything with me like i had to bring
lighting i had to bring all of my
cameras
i brought so much stuff across the
country because i knew that if the
iphone was coming out i needed to have
everything to cover it so it was really
fun because i got to see my family but
also i kind of worked the entire time so
i'm very sad that i had to do that but
this is also
very big news my sister brianne who
she's not really an internet person at
all i even see stars in it i know
it's like are you impressed that looks
yeah that looks like a picture frame
that's a nice picture breeze impressed
i'm impressed
she has not bought her own iphone
in a very long time i think that she had
one of
my other sister jenna's very very very
very old phones her and her husband both
decided
to officially upgrade to the 12 pro max
so it's really amazing because this
phone when you're jumping up
from even the seven or the eighth i mean
it is even a big difference from the 10.
but that's where you're gonna really see
the difference because the iphone 11 if
you do have one
that camera system is so impressive it's
the first time that they integrated the
three camera lens system with the ultra
wide wide and the telephoto but having
this 12 pro
and the 12 pro max add on that addition
to the lidar
plus the dolby vision hdr it does make a
difference and i've been enjoying
editing hdr footage off of the iphone so
much
so while reviewing the 12 and the 12 pro
i also got a chance to check out the
magsafe charger for the first time
the magsafe wallet adapter which is
really cool there's been so many people
that have been making videos like it
falls off of
your phone when you put it in your
pocket and then peter mckinnon made a
video showing like
how are you putting it in your pocket
like if you're putting it in your pocket
trying to make it fall off then yeah
it's gonna fall off for me this is an
accessory that i don't really
want to use i have a separate wallet and
most of the time
i only do apple pay i really only carry
like my id
and one credit card as a backup if apple
pay isn't accepted so doing this first
review was really fun because i had so
much incredible footage we were actually
in maryland and it was right in the
middle of fall
so all of the leaves have changed so i
was able to get some really cool footage
so shortly after that apple updated
their clips app so now you were able to
edit really short clips in
clips you can now shoot vertical video
you can shoot horizontal
you can also do captions at the same
time while you're recording a video so
this is a really cool feature if you
want to add integrated captions into
like your instagram posts or even on
twitter
then i went out on a 5g
uw safari so this is probably one of the
most fun videos that i
have made in a really long time because
i got to sort of just be weird and be
myself and just go out and try to look
for
5g as if i was on a safari hunt in some
foreign land
but i was actually in los angeles the
best part about this video is something
that i didn't even
capture i went into rei so when i went
to the checkout the guy asked me what i
was
going to be doing with the binoculars
like oh are you gonna be doing bird
watching i was like no
i'm gonna go hunt for 5g he's like oh
okay so
like a parody or something and i was
like no this is all seriousness i gotta
go find 5g uw
what was really cool is actually getting
to experience these speeds i've had 5g
phones before but a lot of times when
i'm testing them out you have to
actively go
and search for 5g because it is not
everywhere 5g is
the 5g uw that's the ultra wide band
that's where you're really going to see
those fast speeds we also did a really
fun 12 and 12 pro
camera test went out to palos verdes
which is one of my favorite places in
los
angeles to go and shoot and film because
it's usually pretty secluded and
especially at a time like this where you
don't really want to be around people
and even when you're filming this was a
perfect day
it was wild because as soon as we got
there i was like shoot
it started pouring down rain and the
second that we parked like the skies
opened up it was like
this video was meant to be shot here
what we also did with this too is we put
the 12 pro on a gimbal so i have one of
those little dji osmo mobile 4s
the stabilization already on this thing
is pretty impressive
but when you pair this with that gimbal
i mean this footage looks like it's on a
drone
i also got a chance to chat with
francesca sweet who is an apple
executive
and we talked all about 5g so it's
really cool to hear her
kind of walk me through from apple's
perspective what 5g means for them
because every single iphone
is now 5g enabled 5g it's the future
so around this point everyone started
getting their phones
and that's when it was time for the one
more thing event so apple dropped
this huge event announcing all of their
new m1 macs
which by the way completely just
separate from the iphone these things
are so fast like the m1 chip is just
shook
now that brings us to the 12 pro max and
the 12 mini
i feel like i've been doing kind of all
of the same sort of videos and unboxings
the same way so we decided to shoot like
this really fun
slow-mo montage of unboxing both of them
and
this is really cool but it took us a
very long time to get all of these shots
because we had to be very precise the
focus had to be perfect and we were
shooting it in slow-mo so i had to
either go very quickly at opening it but
then i was going too fast and then we'd
miss the shot so this little intro
montage took us a really long time but
it was really fun to shoot
so for my 12 pro max and pro mini video
i wanted to go somewhere and i
basically only had one single day so we
decided to drive to joshua tree
at like thursday night super late we
shot all day friday
a little bit saturday drove back home
had to film some more
and then sunday edited all day and then
posted the video on monday so a lot of
these videos are very quick turnaround
times
what was great though about shooting at
joshua tree is we were really able to
showcase
like how good this dynamic range is when
you're shooting outside being able to
pull down the highlights in the sky
so that you don't lose any detail for me
that's really important and when i'm
editing i really like to kind of turn
down my contrast i like to up the
saturation so i really like to have the
colors pop
and kind of have that contrasty look
also got a chance to check out the
magsafe duo charger so this is kind of
apple's two-in-one charger for your
apple watch and
the mag safe charger so this is such a
small portable compact little charger
that i wish
that all of the times that i've been
traveling last year that this was
something that was out
but now i'm not really traveling as much
anymore so it just kind of sits on my
desk and it folds up so nice and cute
like look at that
the thing that surprised me the most
though about the iphone 12 pro max is
that telephoto i really didn't think the
two and a half times
zoom was gonna make that much of a
difference until i tried it
and put it side by side with the iphone
12 pro
and i was like wow all right you know
what this is
this is worth it i love the form factor
and the size of the 12 pro but i really
just want that better camera system so
because it does have the sensor shift
technology in the wide angle lens you
are getting a much more stable shot in
the pro max as opposed to the 12 pro
or the 12. i didn't think it was going
to make that much of a difference but
when you start looking for it you see it
i shot a very fun
photo and video camera test so if you
guys want to watch that full thing you
can check that out i basically tested
out all four of the iphones and kind of
put them up
side by side and the thing that i
noticed is all four of them take
incredible photos and videos
but if you do decide to go with the 12
you're not gonna have
that three camera system like the pros
so you're only gonna have the ultra wide
and the wide angle but the good news is
you are getting dolby vision hdr
on all four of the phones you are only
able to shoot 30 frames a second on the
12s and on the 12 pro you do get up to
60 frames a second so if you do plan on
ever wanting to slow down that footage
then the pro
is definitely the way to go and also
they released the homepod mini i
completely forgot about that
that thing is so cute i feel like the
homepod mini is perfect for smaller
spaces i mean if you have an apartment
or just like a small little shelf like
the homepod vinnie just looks so much
better than the large version and if you
are in a smaller space
having that large homepod is definitely
unnecessary i've really been enjoying
having those as a stereo pair so i
paired them with my apple tv so i've
been using them kind of as my home
theater system now
i guess last but not least even though
this isn't iphone related i did do
a pretty extensive review on the new m1
max for the new macbook air
and the new macbook and the mac mini i
did this really fun
format where i kind of opened up my own
i guess
mac depot store i do have some plans of
kind of continuing that and making it
more of a series so
be sure to look out for that but if you
haven't checked that out i will also put
a link in the description if you want to
to see me as if i was at a genius bar
except it's not it's ijustine's virtual
mac depot i opened up a store in my
house
and let you guys virtually ask me
questions well thank you guys for
watching i just kind of wanted to recap
everything that i've talked about for
the past couple of months regarding the
iphone and apple because there's so
much content and so much tech has been
coming out that it is
incredibly overwhelming be sure to leave
me some comments i'm always reading
those and talking to you guys so i will
see you in my next video
until then i guess i'll see you in the
comments see ya